[Music]
i was trying to think up
a name for a fantasy world that might
have been created by
children and what i came up with was
booyah moon which sounds like a
childhood place to me it's a place
that's
supposed to be very very beautiful and
at the same time
very dangerous where time doesn't run
the way that it does
on earth i wanted it to feel like the
inside
of a dream that's actually become real
[Music]
moon is part of that you know sort of
stephen king multiverse
it is a place that was a bit of a
salvation
for scot and also a desperate necessity
[Music]
almost called a purgatory there are
people that get kind of stuck there
it's also a place that people retreat
from the world
that's the place where she finds her
sister
all this works in a very symbolic way in
a very metaphorical way
because even though this world's fantasy
are
very fantastical and unreal
they do represent certain desires and
illusions and
situations that we experience as human
the whole interesting thing about booyah
moon is stephen king's absolutely
adamant it's real
you